Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
In this video,we're tackling a hard interview question: The Infamous Skyline Problem.
I'll explain my C++solution
which beat 98.24% of other submissions in speed and 100% in memory.
In case you've neverlooked at a beautiful city view and thought:
I wonder what mathematical function describes thisskyline.
Don't worry.
The more practical view of the problem is finding the pointwise max of a bunchof piecewise functions.
But thinking about it like buildings is just easier to visualize.
We're givena bunch of buildings represented by their left, right and height.
And we're supposed to producethe skyline formed by those buildings
which are represented by x, y points.
That descriptionis a bit dense. So, let's look at it visually.
First, we have the buildings defined by theirleft and right x coordinates and their height.
Their outline together with the implicit ground atheight zero forms a skyline.
Because the buildings are perfectly level and two-dimensional,
theskyline itself is piecewise rectangular describedby its corners.
Since the rectangles are perfectlylevel,
we don't need all the corners to describe the skyline.
Since whenever there is a changein height, the x-coordinate doesn't change.
That means, we can fully specify the skyline using justthe points where the height changed
which is what the problem statement for this problem expects.
So, we take in the buildings as a list of left, right, height coordinates
And we output the skylinedefined by those points where the height changes
Okay, let's get to the code.
The first thing I wantto point out is this horrible decision that leetcode has made.
According to leetcode, buildings andpoints are represented by standard vectors of ints.
Even though both of these things havefixed sizes
where structs like these or at the very least arrays would be thefastest choice
we're forced to use a vector.
I'll use these using declarations for now.
But atthe end, I'll show you how we can go way faster if we just use fixed size types.
I'll start offdefining these getters for the building and point attributes.
Don't risk using the wrong index byaccident.
These are all going to be optimized away anyway.
Again, if buildings and points were juststructs,
we wouldn't need any of these functions.
Okay, let's get to computing the actual skyline.
First, let's make a vector of points to hold the skyline to return.
We're going to reserve two timesas many points as there are buildings
because a building can contribute at most two points to theskyline.
The algorithm I'm going to describe is a single pass algorithm
which means that we're justgoing to look at each building once.
And by the end of it, we'll have the entire skyline.
The idea is asfollows.
We loop through the buildings one by one.
When we read in a building,
the goal of thatiteration is to compute all the points of theskyline up to
and including the left endpointof the current building.
As you can see in the animation,
sometimes that means adding a pointat the current building.
Sometimes it means filling in points from right edges of previousbuildings.
And sometimes no new points are added.
First, let's focus on how do we tell if we needto add a point for the current building's leftendpoint.
Well, we only add a new point to theskyline if the tallest building so far changes.
So, in particular, we need to be keepingtrack of what's the tallest building so far.
We'll use a priority queue thatcompares buildings by their heights
in order to keep track of which building isthe tallest that we haven't accounted for yet.
Here's how you define a custom compare function.
And here's the priority queue that we're using.
We're just using a standard vector asthe underlying container for the queue.
We're also doing a little trick here inorder to reserve space for the priority queue.
We create the vector that we want to use asthe underlying storage for the priority queue
and reserve the number of elements that wewant.
In this case, we reserve enough space for the total number of buildings.
Since, atmost, all of the buildings can be active.
One of the constructors of the priorityqueue then allows you to steal that data.
We chose a priority queue because we wantconstant time lookup of the tallest thing.
And it only costs us logn time to insertand remove.
Okay, back to the loop.
Whenever we see a new building, we go ahead and pushit on to our active list.
Then we go ahead and try to update the skyline with the currentx value and whatever the new tallest height is.
Getting the maximum height is prettystraightforward.
Just look at the top thing on the priority queue or 0 if the queue is empty.
Here'swhere we're using that the skyline is zero in the absence of any buildings.
Updating the skyline justinvolves pushing the x, y coordinate onto the back of the vector.
Of course, we only add a pointto the skyline if it changes the height.
So, if we try to push something that has the same heightas whatever is on the back of the skyline already,
we just do nothing.
If all the buildings hadunique left endpoints, then this would actually be fine.
But it is possible that the two buildingsboth have the same left endpoint.
If multiple buildings all have the same left endpoint,
I'mstill going to add just one point to the skyline.
For that reason, I just push all of the buildingsthat have the same left endpoint in the sameiteration of the loop.
So, this works for findingthe skyline points that are left endpoints at the beginning of buildings.
But what about ones thatare defined by the right endpoints of buildings?
When we go to the next iteration of the loop,
it's possible that we missed many right endpoints.
Whenever our current x exceeds the right endpoint of the tallest building,
that means that the tallest building is about to drop off.
And that'sa candidate for when we need to add a new skyline point.
The logic for this one is a little bitcomplicated.
So, let's put it in its own function.
So, here's the function.
The purpose of thisfunction is to handle the case when the tallest active building is about to drop off.
I know it'sjust a few lines.
But there's a lot of thought that goes into making sure that they do the correctthing.
The idea is simple.
Just pop off whatever the tallest thing is and then try to add a newskyline point at whatever the new tallest thing is.
The subtle issue here is that, for speed,
we don't want to go through the entire priority queue
and get rid of all ofthe things that should be deactivated.
That means that whenever we pop something off thequeue,
the next tallest thing might be something
that should have been removed a long time ago.
We keep popping things off the top
until we see something whose right endpoint is strictly further
than the tallest building that we started with.
Any tallest building whose right endpoint is leftof our original tallest building's right endpoint,
cannot be part of the skyline.
It was either ashorter building that had the same right endpoint
or it was something that should havebeen removed from a previous iteration
that we didn't remove in order to avoidtraversing the entire priority queue.
That's why we're removing a bunch ofthings but only update the skyline once.
That also explains the name of the function.
We keep popping off the tallest thing
until the right endpoint that we find ispast the current tallest right endpoint.
Returning back to the main loop.
We keep poppingoff the tallest building and stale buildings
updating the skyline until we find that thetallest thing remaining
has a right endpoint further than our current x
oruntil nothing active is left.
This takes care of everything up until the end.
But there's a little bit more work to do after weget to the end of the buildings.
We basically just pretend that there's a building at infinity.
Andthen pop off all of the remaining active buildings.
Then of course don't forget to return the skyline.
I wrote a bunch of tests.
And I'm timing both how long it takes in total.
And how long it takesjust to run the actual get skyline function.
Running it a bunch of times,
we see that it passesall of my tests and does decent in terms of timing.
But I think we can do better thanthat.
I looked back at the code and once we put something into the active queue,
wenever actually use anything except for its height and its right endpoint.
We never use the leftendpoint.
Additionally, since this active queue is something that's internal to our algorithm,
we can choose a better data type than a vector.
Here, we define a fixed size struct that'sjust the right and the height of the building.
And we give it an explicit constructor to converta building into just the right and height.
Then we change our compare function and our priorityqueue
to take in these fixed size structures instead of vectors.
This allows us to get rid oftwo of our getters.
Then everywhere that we used getRight or getHeight,
we change to dot writeor dot height.
Also, instead of pushing building objects onto our active queue,
we're now pushingthese fixed size structs onto the active queue.
Making this change took the total testtime about 5 milliseconds down
both in the total test time and timespent in the getSkyline function.
Okay, remember the comment that I made atthe beginning
where I said that using avector events here was a mistake?
Watch whathappens just by switching to fixed size arrays.
Making no other changes, our times are nowdown to 6 milliseconds and 1 millisecond.
We went from 40 and 15 down to about 6 and 1 doingnothing but changing to fixed size arrays.
And this I think is one of the biggest problems withleetcode.
This was supposed to be a competition for how fast you can make this algorithm go.
Butby telling you that a building and a point are supposed to be vectors of ints,
they've alreadyslowed your program down by a factor of 5.
This just goes to show that designing a goodinterface
and choosing your problem statementas carefully
and as correctly aspossible can really make a difference.
If you do something, like, choose an inappropriatetype for your function or return type,
you can end up really slowing down the executionof your function.
and then you also end up slowing down other things
that now have to passdata around, reformat data into vectors in order to call the function.
Anyway, I hope youenjoyed this solution.
If you did, don't forget to subscribe.
As always, thank you to my patronsand donors. I really appreciate your support.
If you especially like the video, please considerbecoming a patron.
Thanks and see you next time.